In constant tension
In the west philippine sea there are still some of us
The angry ones
Wondering
And asking questions
That if America is really there for the Philippines
Why doesn't it help
Just like the red supply mission
Where it is always problematic
of the Philippine military
But if America is asked according to the forestar
Admiral Commander of the us navy pacific cleat
The Philippines is not asking for help
About missions
In the west philippine sea
But they are ready
In case the Philippines calls
The pumping of china's water
To the philippine coast guards
Anya is not included in the agreement
The united states philippine mutual defense treaty
But if china uses ammunition
America's military will automatically grow in force
America has long inherited china's gesture
In the west philippine sea
That's why
In the resupply mission carried out
The philippine Coast Guards
I feel good
Is ready
And its aircraft are on guard
The us flew their ant man air vehicle
That mq one c gray eagle
Not just taking videos
It can do photography and photography
Because it also has loaded missiles
Long range and long flight
This draw is endurance
That's why it was the one who watched before
When Marawi seeds
Besides that
It was also in the air of the west philippine sea then
The pe pocido of the us navy
So what exactly is its ability to pose this
Let's watch
Our old video about this plane
The posaid looks like a commercial plane
Not as sexy
f twenty two raptors and f thirty five
But can keep up
The ph is a maritime patrol aircraft
That we use
In surveillance missions
Due to the extremely high tech of vision sensors
At its radar system
It is capable of detecting submarines
That's why they also call it a submarine hunter
There is a top speed that will reach
Nine hundred kilometers per hour
Three hundred sixty degree coverage
and airborne reader systems
Being able to detect flying and moving objects
That will reach
At three hundred seventy kilometers
Cameras that can zoom even a few miles away
That's clear
and detailed
In addition to that,
it is also connected
In the surveillance drone of us
And in armaments,
it has eleven hard points
ejm eighty four
Slammer ertos surface
Harporn antiship missiles mk fifty four and torpedos
It takes nine navies to fly it
A pilot
Co pilot
And seven will operate the radar
Three sixty cameras and loaded missiles
Apart from these surveillances we are ready
The two warships of the philippine navy then
Just a few kilometers away
From your insul
And they are ready
On what china could possibly do
As I mentioned before in our previous videos
China will not use weapons
Except for the water canon
China knows that by the time they release ammunition
They will face America
So is china's strategy
Is blocking radio challenge and water bombing